today's question from Nicole in Utah
she asks I'm on baby step number two and
I'm torn between taking up more shifts
at work and maybe even getting a side
gig at night to pay the debt off faster
and I'm feeling guilty about the time it
would take away from my daughters how do
I find a balance between feeling the mom
guilt well when my kids were little we
were broke and I had to work I didn't
have a choice
it wasn't trying to achieve a goal it
was trying to eat right and I had to
work and then we were starting this
business the kids were small still and
businesses don't start on 40 hours a
week I had work and all of our kids
turned out none of them are permanently
damaged another mother was there with
them and and you know she will tell you
she felt like a single mom part of the
time so very few things in life get
achieved by people who are Trenton on a
40-hour work week they just don't and so
you know you do you want to work extra
jobs and never see your kids for the
next ten years
no but do you want to do it for eight
months so that you get to see your kids
in a quality situation from now on it's
lived like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else work like
no one else so that later you can work
like no one else I work now because I
want to right now cuz I need to in any
stretch I just enjoy what I do right and
I don't need the money I don't need that
I take the money it's a scorecard I want
to keep score but but it's not I'm not I
don't have anything driving me like
necessities you know or anything like
that I I work because I want to now but
and I work when I want to and where I
want to now and so somebody calls and
says you know and once you go over here
and do this I just say no I think I
don't think I wanna do that right and so
if you work like no one else later you
get to work
like no one else I don't think your
children are gonna be damaged from a
period of time now again here's the
problem you're gonna have a financial
trouble and always have the wolf at the
door if you don't do this for for ten
years if you don't do this for ten
months and that stress poisons your kids
it poisons your family tree yeah right
that constant we're gonna be able to eat
or even have the lights gonna get shut
off that constant worry
that's generational that goes with you
and also I'm gonna really recommend
Nicole she get a couple of friends she
can sit down with I think there's an
industry now around mom guilt mom guilt
the more a producing mom guilt off the
conveyor belt like never before more I
can keep mom feet from being firmly
planted in who she is and that she has
value and that her kids are gonna be
okay
I think I'm my little gnarly world i buy
stuff humpback grandmother I can promise
you she didn't have mom killed she was
German descent right now whack you with
a wooden spoon woman right she didn't
have mom guilt yeah you know if one of
her kids had suggested they weren't
being nurtured she would have fed them a
biscuit ecosystem we've created where
moms can't win you can't work you can't
stay at home it's just it's the only way
through that is with the community that
will prop you up and you have less low
days and those high days and but yeah
I'm with you man my wife and I worked
crazy we had six figures worth of debt
we we just we lived nuts
we lived nuts for how long about 18
months we've had a Haunter $6,000 we
moved into a residence hall we did some
crazy stuff you went bananas for 18
months and for the rest of your life
then you're free that's that's right
that's a fair trade
that's it was a fir art for our family
was a wonderful trade yeah wonder if any
of your kids aren't in counseling
because of that they're gonna be in for
other reasons but it's cuz I'm their dad
no because there's that their mom's
pretty extraordinary point right all
right
they're doing just fine just fine